patron video requests Tom wait for a
trailer that just happens to be
something people are actually watching
right now normally they're like old ass
videos it's called the outsider it's a
Netflix original starring Yared Leto oh
boy let's get to it yo
[Music]
it's a fable the koi fish who can swim
at the waterfall
[Music]
well I understand in life sometimes we
fight the current other times it's
important to follow the white man in
Japan a lot of internic last similar to
the Camino koozies a choice
the user don't give a [ __ ] about their
traditions whatever the [ __ ] it is that
year to try to explain to me that's the
way this Jared Leto's gonna kill them
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
I know all those people by the way I
just know all of them personally I am
well informed I know my foreign markets
I can no one's business movie about
Yakuza yeah Jared Leto touring share
like what what what if white guy wanted
to do it yeah man I think all these
movies are better when you have a white
guy in there as the lead that's how I'm
really able to relate to this yeah
couldn't be any old Japanese guy
honestly if it was an Asian actor I just
wouldn't care just wouldn't buy it fact
that it's a white American famous dude
that's what makes it believable now I'm
drawn to it Thank You Jared I mentioned
Tony McGuire requested this video no no
I didn't he just a patron video requests
it or not you want to know my honest
opinion Netflix has a has a weird streak
with movies yes they fluctuate from
terrible to really good this I don't
really have faith in to be honest I mean
there's stuff a bad that looks cool the
shot well like every Netflix movie Jared
Leto's a really good actor I'm not gonna
give him Joker [ __ ] crap right now
really good actor if anything this looks
like it could be a cool b-movie I don't
think it's gonna be that I think it's
gonna be a very self-serious film that's
gonna try to be a heavy weighty dramatic
thriller but I think like you should
just God the b-movie route with this
this is doing other than being like oh
yeah this Outsiders trying to join the
Yakuza does he know what he's getting
into is he prepared for what's well it's
it seems like it's like right post-world
War two
right that's what I picked up as the
vibe I picked up on what are you saying
we won the the one guy he's talking to
we want I don't know there's no real
clear definition that's just what I
again that's a cool bit of like
background context but in like the
active the the the main action of this
movie all I grabbed from this trailer
was like oh yeah he's joining up and
it's probably gonna be tough for him
because this is white guy sometimes the
Netflix trailers for from their movies
feel like they're promoting a show
sometimes I feel like their show
trailers are better than their movie
lazer show trailers feel like a movie
trailer and then their movie trailers
feel like they're promoting a show yeah
I always have to check I'm always like
which one is it I don't know jack about
who this guy is under then he's white
dude joining the Yakuza other than I'm
supposed to like him because he's Jared
Leto and like what exactly is the plot
of this movie it doesn't really suppose
anything unique being offered here it
just seems like a generic film what's
unique about other than like I like
seeing violence but it doesn't look like
it's filled with violence is it gonna be
the Last Samurai but with the Yakuza are
really samurai Yakuza are the exact same
writer and accusal like him yeah it
doesn't look like anyone's like no no no
stick with it man you got a we we got
plans you're you're integral to our
operations is that no Jared Leto
actually looks mercy trying to look semi
Japanese well I mean he's got the
haircut and the super black hair yeah I
mean I don't think they're trying to
make him look I think it's kind of both
he's got to have the slicked black
hairdo because that's you Cuza
but yeah I get in a sense that it is
kind of like trying to make him look
Japanese just because of what the Yakuza
is it feels like this is a cooler
trailer than what the film will actually
be but hey if it comes out and it was
good am I gonna go away and wanting to
hate it I'm just saying my initial
impression off of it looks like it
doesn't it looks generic I'm sure this
will be an okay time it's a cool idea
this trailer just didn't sue per gram me
I guess I'm just so sick of white man
and Asian world yeah we've done it so
many what I let's just let's just do
something Asian max you just did Iron
Fist Olivia the comics he's a white guy
but come on man this is an original
movie bean lots of good Japanese act
yeah but you know what it'd be cool to
see Jarrell it'll kick some ass I can't
remember the last time I saw him kick
some ass you in a fight club he just
gets his ass kicked so I'd be nice to
see him kick panic room did he kick an
ass in panic room at least broke in I'm
a little [ __ ] in panic room too isn't
it
oh maybe he's got cornrows David what
your hires him to be is anticipated
Jared I got a great role for you what's
it this time
your [ __ ]
well thanks Tony McGee I mean I still
enjoy watching you then it's fun to not
love something once in a while you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bellow get notified
every time one of our vids is up full
leg TV show reactions and music videos
over on our patreon as well as weekly
Q&A see you over there